This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Religions tell us they have the key to our best lives. Advice columnists tell us how to solve problems in our relationships. And airport bookstores are stuffed with tombs on how to grow rich, manage our time better, and build effective habits. All these sources of counsel can teach us valuable skills, such as planning, patience, and perseverance. These can be vitally important to success. But in a world overflowing with useful advice,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。宗教告诉我们，他们掌握着我们过上最好生活的钥匙。建议专栏作家告诉我们如何解决人际关系中的问题。机场书店里塞满了关于如何致富、更好地管理时间以及养成有效习惯的巨著。所有这些建议来源都能教会我们宝贵的技能，例如计划、耐心和毅力。这些对于成功至关重要。但在一个充斥着有用建议的世界里，
why do so many of us feel stuck? How is it even the very successful? Often feel like there is something missing from their lives. Why do so many people spend years wistfully thinking about choices they might have made? One answer to that problem? Many of us are leading lives that are misaligned with our own deepest values and preferences. This week on Hidden Brain, what psychology can teach us about living our most authentic lives. When you're a kid, grownups ask you what you want to do when you're an adult.
为什么我们中有这么多人感到困惑？为什么即使是非常成功的人，也常常觉得生活中缺少了什么？为什么这么多人花多年时间，带着遗憾去思考他们本可以做出的选择？这个问题的答案之一是什么？我们许多人所过的生活，与我们自己内心深处最真实的价值观和偏好并不一致。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨心理学能教会我们什么，关于如何过上最真实的生活。当你还是个孩子时，大人们会问你长大后想做什么。
When you're a teenager, college counselors ask you what you want to study. Once you join the workforce, managers ask you what your goals are for the next few years. At every stage, we are really being asked the same question. What do you want to do with your life? At the University of Missouri, psychologists Ken Sheldon studies the science of knowing what to want, how to set your sights on targets
当你十几岁时，大学辅导员会问你想学什么。一旦你进入职场，经理会问你未来几年的目标是什么。在每一个阶段，我们实际上都被问到同一个问题。你想用你的生命做什么？在密苏里大学，心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究了“知道自己想要什么”的科学，以及如何设定你的目标，
that will actually make you happy if you achieve them. Ken Sheldon, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hey, I'm happy to be here. I want to take you back to 1981, Ken. You just finished college and moved to Seattle. You wanted to become a musician. You started a band. How did it go?
这些目标一旦实现，确实会让你感到快乐。肯·谢尔顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，很高兴来到这里。肯，我想带你回到1981年。你刚大学毕业，搬到了西雅图。你想成为一名音乐家。你组建了一个乐队。进展如何？
Rock musicians can be kind of flaky and unreliable and we were all in our 20s and everybody had different goals. Everybody was kind of self-centered and they might not have been committed the way we thought that they were or maybe the guitarist slept with the singer unexpectedly and you know there's a lot of things that can just get in the way of having a smoothly functioning unit. We just weren't able to make the agreements and follow through with them that we would have needed to make real progress. I understand that at one point you were recording songs for a radio song contest and things didn't quite go smoothly. Yeah, I had recorded my tracks on the song that we were going to submit
摇滚乐手可能有点反复无常、不可靠，我们当时都20多岁，每个人都有不同的目标。每个人都有点以自我为中心，他们可能不像我们想象的那样投入，或者吉他手可能意外地和歌手睡了，你知道，有很多事情会阻碍一个顺利运作的团队。我们就是无法达成协议并执行下去，而这正是我们取得真正进展所需要的。我听说有一次你们在为电台歌曲比赛录制歌曲，事情进展得不太顺利。是的，我录制了我们准备提交给
to this contest. I left for a weekend hiking trip, expecting that the bandmates would put their tracks down so we could send in the song of the next Monday. And I got back and nobody had done anything. And I was very disappointed and I remember walking in the rain, it was Seattle, wondering what to do next, and coming to the decision that this is probably not gonna give me a way to make a living, and that music, or at least this particular band, episode was not gonna work out,
这次比赛的歌曲的音轨。我出发去进行周末徒步旅行，期待着乐队成员能录好他们的音轨，这样我们就能在下周一寄出这首歌。但我回来时，什么都没做。我非常失望，我记得走在雨中，那是西雅图，思考着下一步该做什么，并得出了一个结论：这可能无法让我以此为生，而且音乐，或者至少这个特定的乐队，这一篇章是行不通的，
and that I needed to get serious about maybe something else. What happened to Ken, of course, has happened to millions of people. Maybe it's happening to you right now. You set your heart on something and then find the thing you wanted, doesn't look anything like the thing you thought you wanted. So Ken did what lots of us do. He flailed around looking for something new. He signed up for a master's program. Yeah, it was a program at Seattle University in existential phenomenological psychotherapy.
我需要认真考虑做点别的事情。当然，发生在肯身上的事，也发生在数百万人身上。也许现在正发生在你身上。你全心全意投入某件事，然后发现你想要的东西，和你以为自己想要的东西完全不一样。所以肯做了我们许多人都会做的事。他四处摸索，寻找新的东西。他报名参加了一个硕士课程。是的，那是西雅图大学的一个存在主义现象学心理治疗项目。
Wow. That's a lot of syllables, but it is a certain tradition within existential philosophy and counseling psychology to to a legitimate approach to helping people. And I was very interested in that program, not so much because I wanted to become a therapist, but more because I've always just been very theoretically oriented. And these were new ideas that I didn't understand that seemed like they might be very relevant to the search for clarity,
哇。那有很多音节，但这是存在主义哲学和咨询心理学中的一个特定传统，是一种帮助人们的合法方法。我对那个项目非常感兴趣，不是因为我想成为一名治疗师，而是因为我一直非常注重理论。这些是我以前不了解的新想法，看起来可能与寻找清晰度非常相关，
a search for what to do with myself. Again, Ken was doing what lots of us do. We looked to the outside world to give us answers to questions about what we should do with our lives. Ken's foray into existential phenomenological psychotherapy was short-lived. The answers he was looking for were not forthcoming. I really enjoyed the year. My fellow classmates, we formed a tight cohort.
寻找我该如何对待自己。同样，肯在做我们许多人都会做的事。我们向外部世界寻求答案，以解决关于我们应该如何生活的问题。肯对存在主义现象学心理治疗的尝试是短暂的。他寻找的答案并没有出现。我真的很享受那一年。我的同学们，我们组成了一个紧密的群体。
We did things together. I learned a lot. And the main thing I learned was that I didn't think the answers I was looking for were going to come from that area of knowledge. So what did you do? Well, I once again stopped doing that. I dropped out after the first year. And in the end, I was felt kind of stuck. I was living in Seattle. The jobs I was working were not very well paying, very high status, but here I was, a Duke graduate, you know, maybe I should be doing better than that. So I was in a sort of
我们一起做事情。我学到了很多。我学到的最重要的一点是，我不认为我寻找的答案会来自那个知识领域。那你做了什么？嗯，我再次停止了那样做。我在第一年后退学了。最后，我感到有点困惑。我住在西雅图。我做的工作薪水不高，地位也不高，但我是杜克大学的毕业生，你知道，也许我应该做得更好。所以我处于一种
period of really, really not knowing what to do next. In addition to not knowing what to do next, Ken felt like he was not measuring up. He sensed a world expected more from him and his impressive college degree. He expected more from himself. He felt lost. Still looking for answers, he signed up for a workshop that was all the rage in the 1970s and early 80s. It was called the AirHard Seminar's Training or S Training. Yeah, the S Training was created by Warner AirHard.
真的、真的不知道下一步该做什么的时期。除了不知道下一步该做什么，肯还觉得自己的表现不尽如人意。他感觉到世界对他和他令人印象深刻的大学学位有更高的期望。他对自己也有更高的期望。他感到迷茫。仍在寻找答案的他，报名参加了一个在20世纪70年代和80年代初非常流行的研讨会。它被称为“AirHard研讨会培训”或“S培训”。是的，S培训是由华纳·艾哈德（Warner AirHard）创建的。
It is not a spiritual guru. He was actually a salesman who read a lot about optimal performance and communication and what is the mind and mind training classes he tried them all and then he created his own version called the S training. And it wasn't a spiritual thing, it was actually designed to train you to understand your own mind and to control it better. I understand that at one point you had this training with a 60-hour course spread across two weekends. To describe the course to me, what happened and what would you learn and how to end it? Yeah, but the way the training was set up, you'd be seated in a ballroom. They'd rent a hotel ballroom and they'd have chairs lined up. And so there would be two or three hundred of you lined up in your chairs.
他不是什么精神导师。他实际上是一个推销员，读了很多关于最佳表现和沟通的书，以及什么是思维，他尝试了所有的思维训练课程，然后创建了自己的版本，称为S培训。这不是什么精神层面的东西，它实际上旨在训练你理解自己的思维并更好地控制它。我听说有一次你参加了这个培训，这是一个跨越两个周末的60小时课程。向我描述一下这个课程，发生了什么，你学到了什么，它是如何结束的？是的，培训的设置方式是，你坐在宴会厅里。他们会租一个酒店宴会厅，把椅子排成行。所以会有两三百人坐在椅子上。
And then the trainer would come out and there would be volunteers who would bring microphones to people to speak into when they wanted to say something. And the trainer led us to a variety of explorations, processes, activities designed to show us how our minds work and how they're currently not working and training us to work them better. I understand the course guaranteed enlightenment at the end of the second weekend.
然后培训师会出来，会有志愿者拿着麦克风给想说话的人。培训师引导我们进行了各种探索、过程和活动，旨在向我们展示我们的思维是如何运作的，它们目前是如何运作不良的，并训练我们更好地运作它们。我听说该课程保证在第二个周末结束时实现启蒙。
That's right, that was actually the thing that attracted me to it most. I wasn't sure that I needed a self-help training, but that promise of guaranteed enlightenment, I was fascinated to find out what that was going to be. And so what happened the second weekend? Well so we're on day four at Sunday of the second weekend and it's sort of building and building and you're getting closer and closer to the material that they really want to hit
没错，那实际上是最吸引我的地方。我不确定我是否需要自我帮助培训，但那个“保证启蒙”的承诺让我着迷，我想找出那到底是什么。那么第二个周末发生了什么？嗯，我们在第四天，也就是第二个周末的周日，它在不断地积累，你越来越接近他们真正想在最后向你灌输的内容，
you with at the end and the moment of enlightenment was being told that this is it. You're already enlightened. There's only the present moment. This is it. Imagine this must have been something of a letdown for the 200 people in the hall. Yeah, I mean, it sounds like a bait and switch almost.
而启蒙的时刻就是被告知“这就是一切”。你已经开悟了。只有当下。这就是一切。想象一下，这对大厅里的200人来说一定很失望。是的，我的意思是，这听起来几乎像是一种诱饵和转换。
So after the trainer told us this, a people were like, what do you mean this is it? This isn't it. So it's interesting. So in this period of your life, I think you went through what a lot of young people go through. You've just graduated college, you're trying your hand at different things, you're throwing dots at the wall, nothing's really sticking. There must have been a period in your life when it felt, it must have felt quite discouraging. Did that, did thoughts of self-doubt go through your mind at
所以培训师告诉我们这一点后，人们就像是，你是什么意思“这就是一切”？这不是一切。所以这很有趣。所以，在你人生的这个阶段，我想你经历了许多年轻人都会经历的事情。你刚大学毕业，尝试不同的事情，你在墙上乱扔飞镖，没有什么是真正奏效的。你生命中一定有一段时间感到非常沮丧。自我怀疑的想法有没有在你脑海中闪过？
this time in your life? Oh yeah, yeah, I would say that I've had a lot of self-doubt that I've struggled with, but you know, a big part of the self-doubt that I've struggled with, but a big part of the self-doubt involves the knowledge that it's only you who is making the choices in your life. And that's kind of scary. It's all up to me. And I wasn't sure that I was good enough to do what maybe I was capable of doing. A drift and uncertain can ask himself what he wanted from life. The band hadn't worked out.
在你人生的这个阶段？哦，是的，是的，我会说我经历了很多自我怀疑，但我挣扎过，你知道，我挣扎的自我怀疑中很大一部分涉及到一个事实，即只有你自己在生活中做出选择。这有点可怕。一切都取决于我。我不确定我是否足够好，能做我可能能够做的事情。漂泊不定、充满不确定性的肯问自己，他想要从生活中得到什么。乐队没有成功。
The master's program in existential phenomenological psychotherapy turned out to be a bad fit. The S-twork shops were a lead down. Ken had always enjoyed science and big ideas. He decided to enroll in a PhD program in psychology. At first this seemed like another mistake. But several years into the program a teacher came along who changed the way Ken thought about the question of what he should do with his life. This wasn't probably till my fourth year that Robert Evans arrived and I was a little
存在主义现象学心理治疗的硕士课程结果并不适合。S研讨会让人失望。肯一直喜欢科学和宏大的想法。他决定报名参加心理学博士课程。起初这看起来像是另一个错误。但在该项目中几年后，一位老师出现了，他改变了肯对自己应该如何生活这个问题的看法。这可能直到我的第四年，罗伯特·埃文斯（Robert Evans）才出现，在那之前我有点
bit adrift up to that point, but once Bob showed up, I recognized that the research he was doing was fascinating than I really wanted to learn about it. And so what he was doing was a new approach to studying personality, or instead of giving people a trait questionnaires on how extroverted are you and how agreeable and so forth, he gave people a blank sheet of paper. And he said, tell me what you're striving to do. And so there'd be, say, 15 blank lines, and the participant would write down,
漂泊不定，但一旦鲍勃出现，我就认识到他正在做的研究比我真正想了解的要迷人得多。所以他正在做的是一种研究人格的新方法，或者说，他没有给人们发放关于“你有多外向”、“你有多随和”之类的特质问卷，而是给了人们一张白纸。他说，告诉我你正在努力做什么。所以会有，比如说，15个空白行，参与者会写下，
you know, 10, 15 as many as they wanted, things that they are striving to do in their life. And that really intrigued me because it's what I had been trying to do. My whole life was figure out what to strive for. Observing how other people write down the things they were striving for, gave Ken a crucial insight. Yeah, there's a blank piece of paper and people write things down. And if you think about it, how do we know or how do they know they're writing good stuff down? You know, maybe they're just writing down what their mom told them or their friend told them or what society has told them or their friend told them or what society has told them.
你知道，10个、15个，尽可能多地写下他们正在努力在生活中做的事情。这真的引起了我的兴趣，因为这正是我一直试图做的事情。我的一生都在弄清楚该为什么而努力。观察其他人写下他们正在努力做的事情，给了肯一个关键的洞察。是的，有一张白纸，人们写下东西。如果你仔细想想，我们怎么知道或者他们怎么知道他们写的是好东西？你知道，也许他们只是写下了他们妈妈告诉他们的，或者朋友告诉他们的，或者社会告诉他们的。
And so it was only thinking later about, what does the meaning of these goal statements people are giving us that I started to wonder what if they're writing down the wrong things? The hard question can realized wasn't figuring out how to get where you were going. It wasn't figuring out where you wanted to go. When we come back, how to find the answer to that difficult question.
所以，直到后来思考人们给我们的这些目标陈述的含义时，我才开始怀疑，如果他们写错了东西怎么办？肯意识到，困难的问题不是弄清楚如何到达你要去的地方。也不是弄清楚你想去哪里。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何找到那个困难问题的答案。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Ken Sheldon studies how we choose goals for ourselves. His research is found that we often select the wrong goals, that is, we point ourselves in directions that don't ultimately lead to lasting happiness. An important reason for this error is that people don't have a good sense of what will make them happy. One of the main things we find is that people are not very good at all at knowing how achieving their goals will affect them.
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究我们如何为自己选择目标。他的研究发现，我们经常选择错误的目标，也就是说，我们指向的方向最终并不会带来持久的幸福。造成这种错误的一个重要原因是，人们并不清楚什么会让他们快乐。我们发现的主要事情之一是，人们根本不擅长知道实现目标会如何影响他们。
They can have a completely off base feeling that this goal, if I finally get it, is going to make all the difference for me. But then when we actually come back and measure their happiness later on to see how it's been affected or not affected, we often find no change. So one of the biggest reasons that you and others have found that people come up with the wrong goals is that we blindly follow voices in our society that tell us what we ought to want. I want to play you a famous clip from the 1987 movie Wall Street. Michael Douglas plays Gordon Gecko, a wealthy corporate rater who has some strong views about greed. of the evolutionary spirit, greed in all of its forms, greed for life, for money, for love, knowledge, has marked the upward surge of mankind and greed.
他们可能会有一种完全错误的直觉，认为这个目标，如果我最终实现了它，将会为我带来所有的改变。但当我们实际上回来并在以后衡量他们的幸福感，看看它是否受到影响时，我们经常发现没有任何变化。所以，你和其他人发现人们得出错误目标的最大原因之一是，我们盲目地追随社会中告诉我们“应该想要什么”的声音。我想为你播放一段1987年电影《华尔街》中的著名片段。迈克尔·道格拉斯饰演戈登·盖柯（Gordon Gecko），一位富有的企业掠夺者，他对贪婪有一些强烈的看法。进化精神，贪婪的所有形式，对生活、金钱、爱、知识的贪婪，标志着人类的向上激增和贪婪。
You mark my words. We'll not only say, tell our paper, but that other malfunctioning corporation called the USA. Thank you very much. So, Ken, today we might say that Gordon Gecko goes too far, but even if we are not willing to be as explicit as this, can you talk about some of the subtler ways in which society tells us that money and power and status are the ultimate barometers of a successful life? Yeah, well, there's many ways. we're all immersed in a material consumer culture which is trying to get us to buy things, click things, make more money so we can acquire status
记住我的话。我们不仅会说，告诉我们的报纸，还会告诉那个名为美国的其他功能失调的公司。非常感谢。所以，肯，今天我们可能会说戈登·盖柯走得太远了，但即使我们不愿意像这样明确，你能谈谈社会告诉我们金钱、权力和地位是成功生活的终极晴雨表的那些更微妙的方式吗？是的，嗯，有很多方式。我们都沉浸在物质消费文化中，它试图让我们购买东西、点击东西、赚更多的钱，这样我们就可以获得地位
symbols. Not all of this fall for this it depends a lot on the support and relations and connections that we have but if you're not sure what to do and so many of these broader cultural messages are telling you to be greedy, you're pretty prone to at least give that a try to see if it works. Yeah, and I suppose another major way that many of us might end up pursuing the wrong things is that we choose goals set for us by other people in our lives, and very often these might be people whom we love. You know, our parents, our teachers, our friends, people who say they want the best for us by other people in our lives, and very often these might be people who we love. You know our parents, our teachers, our friends, people who say they want the best for us,
象征。并非所有人都落入这个陷阱，这在很大程度上取决于我们拥有的支持、关系和联系，但如果你不确定该做什么，而这么多更广泛的文化信息都在告诉你变得贪婪，你很容易至少尝试一下，看看它是否有效。是的，我想我们许多人最终追求错误事物的另一个主要方式是，我们选择了生活中其他人为我们设定的目标，而且通常这些可能是我们所爱的人。你知道，我们的父母、老师、朋友，那些说他们想要我们最好的人，但实际上可能不知道什么会让我们快乐的人。
but people who might not actually know what will make us happy. Do you hear that from your students as well, Ken? Yeah, that's a very common complaint. College students are still trying to figure out what they want, perhaps independently of their parents. It's their first real opportunity to get away from their parents and explore on their own. And parents often have very firm ideas about what they want their children to do. And it's not a bad thing. In many cases, they
你在你的学生中也听到过这种说法吗，肯？是的，这是一个非常普遍的抱怨。大学生们仍在试图弄清楚他们想要什么，也许是独立于他们的父母。这是他们第一次真正有机会远离父母，独自探索。父母通常对他们想要孩子做什么有非常坚定的想法。这不是一件坏事。在许多情况下，他们
are good ideas, but ultimately parents are not even as good a position as we are to experiment and find what we really want. Parents have goals of their own. They want to acquire the status of having a doctor as a child. And they sometimes can't separate that out from their love and concern for us. So some years ago you were approached by a law professor at Florida State University and Lawrence Krieger wanted to discuss a problem he was seeing among some of his law students. What did he tell you? In his view, you know, in law schools, there's intense competition, there's grading on a curve
是好主意，但最终父母甚至不如我们自己有能力去实验和找到我们真正想要的东西。父母有他们自己的目标。他们想要获得“孩子是医生”的地位。他们有时无法将其与他们对我们的爱和关心分离开来。所以几年前，佛罗里达州立大学的一位法学教授联系了你，劳伦斯·克里格（Lawrence Krieger）想讨论他在一些法学院学生中看到的问题。他告诉了你什么？在他看来，你知道，在法学院，竞争非常激烈，有按曲线评分的制度，
so that even if you learn almost all the material, you might still only get a C. You're trying to get the prestigious positions. You might end up accepting a job because it's the highest paying, even though once upon a time you might have thought you would have hated doing that type of job. So it can be really confusing for students
所以即使你学会了几乎所有的材料，你可能仍然只能得到一个C。你试图获得那些享有声望的职位。你最终可能会接受一份工作，因为它薪水最高，尽管曾经有一段时间你可能认为你会讨厌做那种类型的工作。所以这对学生来说可能真的很困惑，
and Larry was trying to humanize legal education. I understand the two of you went on to co-author a number of studies involving law students and practicing lawyers. Tell me some of what those studies found. Yeah, we've published several studies. Our first came out in 2004. We were able to track a sample of law students over their entire three-year career to see what changes occurred in their well-being
而拉里正试图使法律教育人性化。我听说你们俩后来合著了许多涉及法学院学生和执业律师的研究。告诉我这些研究发现了一些什么。是的，我们发表了几项研究。我们的第一项研究发表于2004年。我们能够追踪一组法学院学生在他们整个三年的职业生涯中的情况，看看他们的幸福感发生了什么变化，
and in their mental state. And the first thing we found was something that had been shown before that their sense of well-being really plummeted quite dramatically and that levels of depression went up quite a bit over the course of the legal career in ways that are more extreme and more concerning than in other professional education. Another thing we found was that there's this paradoxical thing where the students who began with the most idealistic motivation tended to do well. They got good grades in their first year of law school, but that had a sort of corrupting effect where they being the highest graders, they became the highest data students and their their values shifted in the direction of looking good, having status instead of helping others. And so their idealistic motivation
以及他们的心理状态。我们发现的第一件事是之前已经显示过的事情，即他们的幸福感确实急剧下降，并且在法律职业生涯中，抑郁水平上升了很多，其程度比其他专业教育更极端、更令人担忧。我们发现的另一件事是，存在这种矛盾的事情，即那些以最理想主义动机开始的学生往往表现良好。他们在法学院的第一年成绩很好，但这产生了一种腐蚀作用，因为他们是成绩最高的人，他们变成了数据最高的学生，他们的价值观转向了“看起来不错”、“拥有地位”而不是“帮助他人”。所以他们的理想主义动机
turned into much more self-centered motivation over time. Here was a set of ideas to explain why people found it hard, why can himself had found it hard, to figure out what to do with his life. By the time a person is in their early 20s and is making important decisions about careers had found it hard to figure out what to do with his life. By the time a person is in their early 20s and is making important decisions about careers and relationships, they've had a good two decades of indoctrination. Indoctrination from the culture, which tells them what's what's driving for and what is
随着时间的推移变成了更加以自我为中心的动机。这是一套解释为什么人们觉得困难，为什么肯本人觉得困难，去弄清楚他该如何对待自己生活的想法。当一个人20出头并正在做出关于职业的重要决定时，他已经经历了二十年的灌输。来自文化的灌输，告诉他们什么是值得努力的，什么是
not. Indoctrination from parents and well-wishers who have told them what is high status and what is not. And indoctrination from schools, they're often take passion and enthusiasm for a subject and turn it into a race for grades, certificates and academic honors. The irony is, the better one does at each stage, the harder it becomes to ask if you're actually doing what it is you want to do. Soon the systems of carrots and sticks that guides us through adolescence and youth is now
不值得的。来自父母和善意者的灌输，他们告诉他们什么是高地位，什么是低地位。以及来自学校的灌输，他们经常把对学科的热情和热忱变成一场争夺成绩、证书和学术荣誉的竞赛。讽刺的是，一个人在每个阶段做得越好，就越难问自己是否真的在做你想做的事情。很快，引导我们度过青春期和青年时期的胡萝卜加大棒系统，现在
driving us through our careers. In one study of 6,000 practicing lawyers can found that many of these professionals prioritize things that the world had decided should make them happy, Often at the expense of things that actually made them happy Yeah, we were looking at everything about lawyers that we could think of that might affect their well-being that Most people would think are most important like how much money do they make? How high status is their job or did they make partner? But we also included these more psychological variables that we thought would be more important how high status is their job or did they make partner.
正在驱动我们的职业生涯。在一项针对6000名执业律师的研究中，肯发现许多专业人士优先考虑那些世界已经决定应该让他们快乐的事情，通常是以牺牲那些真正让他们快乐的事情为代价。是的，我们研究了关于律师的一切我们能想到的可能影响他们幸福感的事情，大多数人会认为这是最重要的，比如他们赚多少钱？他们的工作地位有多高，或者他们是否成为了合伙人？但我们也包括了这些我们认为更重要的心理变量。
But we also included these more psychological variables that we thought would be more important. Like, do they enjoy and believe in what they're doing? Do they feel like they're making a contribution to the world in what they're doing? And what we found was that, yes, in fact, income correlated with happiness, but it was a pretty small effect, a surprisingly small effect. A much larger effect was their motivation for doing the job. Was it something they wanted to do?
但我们也包括了这些我们认为更重要的心理变量。比如，他们是否享受并相信他们正在做的事情？他们是否觉得自己在所做的事情中为世界做出了贡献？我们发现的是，是的，事实上，收入与幸福感相关，但影响相当小，小得令人惊讶。一个更大的影响是他们做这份工作的动机。这是他们想做的事情吗？
They believed in it. They felt like they were contributing to the world by doing it. And that was a much larger determinant of how happy a person they were. So you've said that unhappy lawyers might represent an especially striking example of a widespread phenomenon, which is that these people are privileging extrinsic motivations over intrinsic motivations. What do you mean by those terms again? Intrinsic motivation is just doing something because you like to do it. It's rewarding, it's interesting doing it as its own reward. Extrinsic motivation is when you don't really like it,
他们相信它吗？他们是否觉得通过做这件事在为世界做出贡献？这是一个人有多快乐的一个更大的决定因素。所以你说过，不快乐的律师可能代表了一个广泛现象的一个特别显著的例子，那就是这些人将外在动机置于内在动机之上。你再次用这些术语是什么意思？内在动机就是做某事，因为你喜欢做它。它是奖励性的，做它本身就是一种奖励，很有趣。外在动机是当你并不真正喜欢它时，
you don't like doing it, but you like what you get from doing it. So you're trying to get a reward from the behavior that will only come after you're finished. I understand that you have done work with Ed D.C., who conducted some of the earliest studies into the nature of intrinsic and extrinsic motivation. Tell me about what you did together. Ed was one of the first people to show that not only is intrinsic motivation real, it really matters to be engaged and interested in what you're doing. He also showed that
你不喜欢做它，但你喜欢从做它中得到的东西。所以你试图从行为中获得只有在你完成后才会出现的奖励。我听说你和埃德·德西（Ed D.C.）合作过，他进行了关于内在和外在动机本质的最早研究。告诉我你们一起做了什么。埃德是第一批证明内在动机不仅是真实的，而且对于参与和对你正在做的事情感兴趣非常重要的人之一。他还表明，
intrinsic motivation is kind of fragile. It can be spoiled pretty easily and he called that the undermining of intrinsic motivation. Ed DC found that these two kinds of motivation had different sources of nourishment. Intrinsic motivation springs up from the inside, it's often shaped by interest and curiosity. Extrinsic motivation comes from the outside. Of course, by the time professionals have embarked on a career, they've had 20 or 30 years of carrots and sticks, thrown at them by family, by teachers, and by the world. The experiments that EDDC ran show that even when people started doing an
内在动机有点脆弱。它很容易被破坏，他称之为“内在动机的削弱”。埃德·德西发现这两种动机有不同的滋养来源。内在动机从内部涌现，通常由兴趣和好奇心塑造。外在动机来自外部。当然，当专业人士开始职业生涯时，他们已经经历了20或30年的胡萝卜加大棒，被家庭、老师和世界所抛弃。埃德·德西进行的实验表明，即使当人们开始做一项
activity because of interest and curiosity, adding external rewards and punishments had the paradoxical effect of destroying intrinsic motivation. And so we did this classic experiments showing that when you pay people to do something, it makes them not want to do it anymore. So if you're solving what should be a fun puzzle that almost everybody likes to do, but you're doing it because you get a dollar for each correct solution, and then you're left alone in the room for a five minute period and you can either do more puzzles or you can pick up a magazine. In that condition,
活动是因为兴趣和好奇心，增加外部奖励和惩罚也会产生破坏内在动机的矛盾效果。所以我们做了这些经典的实验，表明当你付钱给人们做某事时，这会让他们不想再做它了。所以如果你正在解决一个本应该是每个人都喜欢做的有趣谜题，但你做它是为了每个正确的解决方案能得到一美元，然后你被单独留在房间里五分钟，你可以做更多的谜题，或者你可以拿起一本杂志。在这种情况下，
you pick up the magazine or today you bring out your cell phone. On the other hand, the participants in his studies who were just told, hey, check out these puzzles, see if you like them. There was no mention of money. When they were left alone in that room, they kept on trying to do new puzzles. the load in that room, they kept on trying to do new puzzles. They retained their intrinsic motivation. And this has huge implications for how we get people to do things. Do we try to sort of bribe and coerce them using external rewards? I mean, sometimes that's necessary, but it's also very powerful medicine that can spoil an activity maybe maybe for life, for a person. Your child starts to take piano lessons and you increase their allowance when they practice a certain amount. That may keep them practicing for a while, but in
你会拿起杂志，或者今天你会拿出你的手机。另一方面，他研究中的参与者只是被告知，“嘿，看看这些谜题，看看你是否喜欢它们。”没有提到钱。当他们被单独留在那个房间里时，他们继续尝试做新的谜题。他们保留了他们的内在动机。这对我们如何让人们做事情有巨大的影响。我们是否试图通过使用外部奖励来贿赂和强迫他们？我的意思是，有时这是必要的，但它也是一种非常强大的药物，可能会破坏一项活动，也许是终身的。你的孩子开始上钢琴课，你会在他们练习一定量时增加他们的零花钱。这可能会让他们练习一段时间，但从
long run, they're probably going to lose interest because they've lost touch with the inherently enjoyable part of playing the piano. You conducted a real-world study that had some remarkable findings. You're working, of course, at the University of Missouri, which is a very extensive athletic program. Some student athletes at the school are recruits whose tuition and expenses are paid for by athletic scholarships. Others are walk-ons who play just for the fun of it. So one group has a bunch of external incentives to play. The other primarily has internal incentives. Now you've studied these two groups of athletes and their long-term involvement with an enthusiasm for their sport. What do you find, Ken?
长远来看，他们可能会失去兴趣，因为他们已经失去了与弹钢琴本身令人愉快的部分的联系。你进行了一项现实世界的研究，有一些显著的发现。你当然是在密苏里大学工作，那里有一个非常广泛的体育项目。学校里的一些学生运动员是招募来的，他们的学费和费用由体育奖学金支付。其他人是“走后门”进来的（walk-ons），他们只是为了好玩而打球。所以一组人有很多外部激励来打球。另一组主要有内部激励。现在你研究了这两组运动员以及他们对运动的长期参与和热情。你发现了什么，肯？
What we were trying to do was show intrinsic motivation undermining that last for decades, not just a few minutes, right? So DC's early studies showed, you know, in that five-minute period, you wouldn't pick up the puzzle. What we wanted to see was, during that four-year period of college, when you were getting when you were getting everything paid for, did that ruin that sport for the rest of your life.
我们试图做的是展示持续几十年的内在动机削弱，而不仅仅是几分钟，对吧？所以德西早期的研究表明，你知道，在那五分钟里，你不会拿起谜题。我们想看的是，在大学的那四年里，当你得到一切报酬时，这是否会毁掉你余生的那项运动。
And what we found was that the varsity athletes up to 30, 40 years later were much less interested in playing the sport in the present day, or even paying attention to what was happening in the sport, in the colleges or the professional leagues, whereas the students who only participated as walk-ons originally retained their interest in the sport. I mean, that's such a paradoxical finding, isn't it,
我们发现的是，校队运动员在30、40年后对在当今进行这项运动的兴趣要小得多，甚至对大学或职业联赛中发生的运动也不太关注，而最初只是作为“走后门”参与的学生则保留了他们对运动的兴趣。我的意思是，这是一个如此矛盾的发现，不是吗？
because of course, the students who are the varsity players are being rewarded. They're being told we love how you play. We're going to give you these incentives to keep playing. It's really strange that these external incentives seem to damage people's internal drive or love for the sport. Yes, it is strange. You would think that they're so good at the sport.
因为当然，作为校队球员的学生得到了奖励。他们被告知“我们喜欢你的打球方式”。我们将给你这些激励来继续打球。真的很奇怪，这些外部激励似乎损害了人们的内在动力或对运动的热爱。是的，这很奇怪。你会认为他们对这项运动如此擅长。
They've spent so much time practicing it. They were able to earn a scholarship. They should be the ones who really continue to like it. So good at the sport, they've spent so much time practicing it, they were able to earn a scholarship. They should be the ones who really continue to like it. The reason that they don't comes down to the fact that they felt very controlled during their college years. They felt like they had to do it. They'd lose their scholarship if they didn't.
他们花了很多时间练习它。他们能够获得奖学金。他们应该是那些真正继续喜欢它的人。他们之所以不喜欢，是因为他们在大学期间感到非常受控。他们觉得他们必须这样做。如果他们不这样做，他们就会失去奖学金。
People were talking about them on the discussion boards. The fans were criticizing them. The coaches were bossing them around. And so when people feel controlled by their environment or their situation, that really tends to undermine their intrinsic motivation. And so as soon as it appears that it's OK to stop doing it, they're prone to go ahead and stop.
人们在讨论板上谈论他们。粉丝们在批评他们。教练们在对他们指手画脚。所以当人们感到被环境或情况控制时，这确实倾向于削弱他们的内在动机。所以一旦看起来可以停止这样做，他们就倾向于继续并停止。
So I want to summarize where we are. You know, if we want to know what to do with our lives, we need to examine our inclinations and propensities. We should try and hold it bay the signals we get from the outside world about what's truly important. But it turns out that doing these things may not be enough. In some ways, maybe we should go back to the days after you graduated from college. You know, I think you were following your inclinations and propensities when you decided to become
所以我想总结一下我们现在所处的位置。你知道，如果我们想知道如何对待我们的生活，我们需要审视我们的倾向和习性。我们应该尝试抵制我们从外部世界得到的关于什么是真正重要的信号。但事实证明，做这些事情可能还不够。在某些方面，也许我们应该回到你大学毕业后的日子。你知道，我想当你决定成为
a musician. You were not following the dictates of money and power and status. Some of you research is focused on what may be the trickiest problem of all, which is we fail to understand ourselves because when we look inward, we can only see one aspect of our own minds. How so can? Yeah, I think this might be one of those profound problems that we human beings face. The fact that we are kind of stuck in a psychological world that is sort of a simulation of what's going on underneath. We can only be conscious of a limited amount at any moment. And the things that we think in our conscious of
一名音乐家时，你是在追随你的倾向和习性。你没有遵循金钱、权力和地位的指令。你的一些研究集中在可能最棘手的问题上，那就是我们无法理解自己，因为当我们向内看时，我们只能看到我们自己思维的一个方面。怎么会这样，肯？是的，我认为这可能是我们人类面临的那些深刻问题之一。事实上，我们被困在一个心理世界中，这是一种对底层正在发生的事情的模拟。我们在任何时刻都只能意识到有限的数量。而我们思考和意识到的事情
can be very influenced by outside forces and pressures as we've discussed. And so it takes quite a bit of time and work to figure out what you really want to do. Some of this has to do with the fact that when most of us think about our own minds, we think that our minds adjust our conscious minds, but some of your work has looked at the idea
可能会受到我们讨论过的外部力量和压力的很大影响。所以需要相当多的时间和工作来弄清楚你真正想做什么。其中一些与这样一个事实有关，即当我们大多数人思考我们自己的思维时，我们认为我们的思维调整了我们的意识思维，但你的一些工作研究了这个想法，
that a significant portion of our minds, in fact, are hidden away from conscious introspection. Yeah, there's a large tradition in motivation research and in other areas of psychology that sort of revived the idea of the non-conscious mind, not saying that it's Freud's idea of the place where the nasty stuff is hidden. Instead, it's the place where we have habitual inclinations, emerging intuitions, motives that we kind of go after, maybe even without our own awareness. And so it's pretty important to learn to hook up the two minds as much as we can to get our conscious cells to accurately reflect what's going on in there at a deeper level.
即我们思维的很大一部分实际上隐藏在意识内省之外。是的，在动机研究和心理学的其他领域有一个很大的传统，它复兴了非意识思维的想法，不是说它是弗洛伊德关于隐藏肮脏东西的地方的想法。相反，它是我们拥有习惯性倾向、涌现的直觉、动机的地方，我们可能会追求这些，甚至没有我们自己的意识。所以学习尽可能多地连接这两个思维，让我们的意识自我准确地反映那里更深层次正在发生的事情，是非常重要的。
When we come back, how to figure out what's inside, well, your hidden brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologists can't sheldon studies how we come up with the goals that animate our lives. He is the author of freely determined what the new psychology of the Self teaches us about how to live. Cancer is such as found that happiness comes when we bring together the propensities and
当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何弄清楚里面有什么，嗯，你隐藏的大脑。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。心理学家肯·谢尔顿研究我们如何得出那些赋予我们生活活力的目标。他是《自由决定：自我心理学新知教我们如何生活》一书的作者。肯的研究发现，当我们把我们意识到的倾向和
inclinations we are aware of with deeper preferences that lie in our unconscious minds. Can you have a name for this process of successfully matching our goals to our conscious and non-conscious Inclinations and propensities you call this self-concordance. What do you mean by this term? self-concordance is simultaneously a simple and a complex concept People pursuing non-concordant goals are often concept. People pursuing non-concordant goals are often doing something mainly because somebody else wants them to, somebody who's important to them, could be parents, it could be a spouse. Other times, they are trying to be something that they themselves think they
习性与潜意识中更深层的偏好结合起来时，幸福就会到来。肯，你有一个名字来称呼这个成功地将我们的目标与我们的意识和非意识倾向和习性相匹配的过程，你称之为“自我一致性”（self-concordance）。你用这个术语是什么意思？“自我一致性”既是一个简单又是一个复杂的概念。追求非一致性目标的人通常
should be. They've got this idea, maybe it goes way back in their lives of what kind of person they are, and what they need to do to be that kind of person. And the problem with both of these types of motivations is it makes it difficult to hear more subtle signals that are coming up from our non-conscious minds that might help us to realize that this isn't quite yet yet. So, of course, the things that are in our minds that are not consciously accessible to us are by definition not consciously accessible to us. So merely asking ourselves what our non-conscious minds are up to will not give us the answers.
做某事主要是因为别人想要他们这样做，那个对他们很重要的人，可能是父母，可能是配偶。其他时候，他们试图成为他们自己认为应该成为的人。他们有这个想法，也许这可以追溯到他们生活中的很久以前，关于他们是什么样的人，以及他们需要做什么才能成为那种人。这两种动机的问题在于，它使我们难以听到来自我们非意识思维的更微妙的信号，这些信号可能帮助我们意识到这还不是完全正确。所以，当然，我们思维中那些我们无法有意识地接触到的东西，根据定义，我们无法有意识地接触到。所以仅仅问自己我们的非意识思维在做什么，不会给我们答案。
So, you're research has found that one way to get at what's happening in our non-conscious minds is to follow a path that artists, designers, and inventors take as they engage in the process of discovery. What are the steps in this process, again? Yeah, this was a very interesting connection that occurred to me at one point because I used to study creativity. I was my dissertation research topic. And there's an important idea in creativity theory of the four stages of creativity. That you start by asking yourself a question. You don't know the answer.
所以，你的研究发现，了解非意识思维中正在发生的事情的一种方法是，遵循艺术家、设计师和发明家在参与发现过程时所走的路径。这个过程的步骤是什么？是的，这是一个在我某一点上想到的非常有趣的联系，因为我曾经研究过创造力。这是我的博士论文研究主题。创造力理论中有一个关于创造力四个阶段的重要想法。你从问自己一个问题开始。你不知道答案。
You want the solution to the scientific problem or the new approach to painting that seems to be in there, something intriguing is calling to you. So you're asked yourself this question and you don't know the answer. And so then there needs to be an incubation period where you go and think about something else. What happens is that your non-conscious mind keeps working on the problem while you're thinking
你想要科学问题的解决方案，或者似乎在里面的绘画新方法，某种引人入胜的东西在呼唤你。所以你问自己这个问题，而你不知道答案。所以需要一个孵化期，你去思考别的事情。发生的事情是，当你在思考时，你的非意识思维会继续处理这个问题。
about something else, just because you sort of consciously posed that question to yourself. And then you went away and now it's working on it. And so hopefully, along comes a moment of inspiration and a ha moment where some stray thought or idea or image pops up. And you recognize, whoa, that's interesting. What's that about? And you start to work with that idea and you realize that it's the solution to the problem. So this is a very common sort of creative sequence. And my idea was that maybe discovering what we really want is a creative activity. And maybe we can self-prompt this activity. We don't just have to wait for insights out of the blue. We can consciously ask ourselves question like, why am I so unhappy? What
关于其他事情，仅仅是因为你下意识地对自己提出了那个问题。然后你走开了，现在它正在处理这个问题。希望随之而来的是灵光一现的时刻，某个偶然的想法、念头或画面突然浮现。你意识到，哇，这很有趣。这是怎么回事？你开始研究那个想法，并意识到它就是问题的解决方案。所以这是一种非常常见的创造性序列。我的想法是，发现我们真正想要的东西可能是一种创造性活动。也许我们可以自我提示这种活动。我们不必只是等待突如其来的洞察力。我们可以有意识地问自己一些问题，比如，为什么我这么不快乐？什么
do I really want? What's bothering me? What's happening inside of me? And when we ask those questions, we don't know the answer right away, but very often we begin to get hints. So partly what I hear you saying is that this process of preparation is really important. It's important to actually try and grapple with the problem consciously, even if it turns out that the answer lies in our non-conscious minds, because by grappling with something consciously, you're setting the stage, if you will, to have a conversation with your non-conscious mind and to allow something to bubble up. That's exactly right.
我真正想要的是什么？什么在困扰我？我内心发生了什么？当我们问这些问题时，我们不会立刻知道答案，但通常我们会开始得到暗示。所以我听到你说的部分意思是，这种准备过程非常重要。真正尝试有意识地去解决问题是很重要的，即使事实证明答案存在于我们的潜意识中，因为通过有意识地去处理某件事，你是在为与你的潜意识进行对话并让某些东西浮现出来搭建舞台。完全正确。
And a colleague and I now are writing a review article where we're trying to make a firm connection between the phenomenology of conscious choice of asking one's mind questions and neuroscience. What's happening in these brain networks when we do that? And we're finding some really striking points of connection, supporting the idea that when we ask ourselves a question, it puts our brains to work in ways that we don't know about, but that can do an amazing job of helping us. So once a period of preparation has led to a moment of illumination, we then have to
我和一位同事现在正在写一篇综述文章，试图在有意识的选择——即向自己的大脑提问——的现象学与神经科学之间建立牢固的联系。当我们这样做时，这些大脑网络中发生了什么？我们发现了一些非常引人注目的联系点，支持了这样一个观点：当我们问自己一个问题时，它会以我们不知道的方式让大脑开始工作，但这些工作能以惊人的方式帮助我们。因此，一旦准备阶段导致了顿悟时刻，我们就必须
proceed to the stage you call verification. Is that right? Not every revelation we have will pan out. That's true. Not every aha experience is the best or final aha experience. And so life is an experiment. And then we need to test the idea once we become aware of it. And we might realize that no,
进入你所说的验证阶段。对吗？并非我们所有的启示都能成功。那是真的。并非每一次顿悟体验都是最好或最终的顿悟体验。所以生活是一个实验。一旦我们意识到这个想法，我们就需要测试它。我们可能会意识到，不，
we don't want to quit everything and move to Mexico and lay on a beach. That's not really going to be as fulfilling as we think. Let's keep thinking and maybe a better choice will come. In order to know what we really want, we need to get better at attending to subtle thoughts and feelings that many of us have spent lifetimes suppressing. Like many other skills, the ability to listen to yourself can be improved through deliberate practice. Ken says there are techniques that can help. One of them is to use mindfulness meditation, where you're just trying to do nothing.
我们不想辞掉一切搬到墨西哥去躺在沙滩上。那实际上不会像我们想象的那样令人满足。让我们继续思考，也许更好的选择会出现。为了知道我们真正想要什么，我们需要更善于关注许多人花了一辈子去压抑的微妙想法和感受。像许多其他技能一样，倾听自己的能力可以通过刻意练习来提高。肯说有一些技巧可以提供帮助。其中之一是使用正念冥想，在那里你只是试图什么都不做。
You're just being a blank conscious screen and you're trying to watch what pops up and you're trying to stay present and not being sort of sucked away by the next thought or the next fear or emotion. And the usefulness of mindfulness for discovering what you really want is that you're learning how to notice these subtle signals that might be lurking on the fringe of consciousness. You might not recognize those until you develop the skill of really kind of picking up on these subtle things that are happening if you'll just shut up and listen. Can in your book freely determine you write about a character you call Amy. She's not a real person, but an amalgamation of many people you've worked with.
你只是作为一个空白的意识屏幕，试图观察浮现出来的内容，并试图保持当下，而不是被下一个想法或下一种恐惧或情绪所带走。正念对于发现你真正想要的东西的用处在于，你正在学习如何注意到那些可能潜伏在意识边缘的微妙信号。在你培养出真正捕捉这些微妙事物的技能之前，你可能不会意识到这些，如果你只是闭嘴并倾听的话。肯，在你的书《自由决定》中，你写了一个你称之为艾米的虚构人物。她不是一个真实的人，而是你共事过的许多人的集合体。
And you use Amy's story to illustrate your technique of getting to self-concordance. Set things up for me. Who is Amy and what is the challenge she faces? As a college student, Amy was very influenced by a friend who encouraged Amy's interest in the environment and influenced Amy to join groups with her and work for the environment. So that was a big part of Amy's life in college, but then she went to law school and did very well. but she fell prey to this problem I described earlier that the high-performing law students tend to become sort of corrupted by their success. And she ended up as a wealthy partner, extremely successful by conventional
你用艾米的故事来说明你达到自我一致性的技巧。为我铺垫一下。艾米是谁，她面临什么挑战？作为一名大学生，艾米深受一位朋友的影响，这位朋友鼓励艾米对环境产生兴趣，并影响艾米加入小组并为环境工作。所以那是艾米大学生活中很重要的一部分，但后来她上了法学院，表现非常好。但她陷入了我之前描述的那个问题，即高成就的法学院学生往往会被他们的成功所腐蚀。她最终成为了一名富有的合伙人，按照传统的
standards, lawyer working in a big farm in a big city, but she was miserable. And she had no idea why at that point. One weekend she talked to her brother at a family gathering and brother asked some difficult questions, well if you're so miserable, why are you still doing this? And that caused her to start thinking in the way I've described. It set her unconscious mind into motion. And the first effects of that process was when the thought of the woman that she knew back in college popped into her head one day at work. And it had been 25 years. Why was she thinking ever now? And she finally got to a point where she Googled that person and discovered that they ran their own consulting firms for environmental
标准，她在大城市的一家大律所工作，非常成功，但她很痛苦。那时她根本不知道为什么。一个周末，在一次家庭聚会上，她和哥哥谈话，哥哥问了一些尖锐的问题，好吧，如果你这么痛苦，为什么还要做这个？这促使她开始以我描述的方式思考。它让她的潜意识开始运转。那个过程的最初效果是，当她在工作中突然想到大学时认识的那位女性时。那已经是25年前的事了。为什么她现在会想到她？她最终查到了那个人的谷歌信息，发现她们经营着自己的环境咨询公司
issues. And it took a while for Amy to go from this knowledge to saying, well, maybe I'll reach out to her and see, you know, email her and see how she's doing. But when she finally got to that last point, the friend was very glad to hear from Amy. Thought that Amy had skills that she needed and invited Amy to come work with her. And so Amy changed her job. She took a 50% cut in salary and she moved to a different city, but she's way happier now than she was before
艾米从知道这一点到说“也许我会联系她看看，你知道，给她发邮件看看她过得怎么样”花了一段时间。但当她最终走到那最后一步时，朋友很高兴收到艾米的消息。认为艾米拥有她所需要的技能，并邀请艾米来和她一起工作。于是艾米换了工作。她减薪50%，搬到了另一个城市，但她现在比以前快乐多了
because she has gotten back to those early adult interests and making a difference in the world. So in terms of the specific techniques that you mentioned a second ago, the idea of preparation, illumination and verification, how does Amy's story represent those stages can? Nothing happened until she started to ask herself, what's the problem? What do I really want? And then nothing happened after that for quite some time because it was a big problem. and it took a while for her non-conscious mind to process it. But then that mind found ways to bring to her attention this relevant image from her past.
因为她找回了那些早年的兴趣，并在世界上发挥了作用。那么，就你刚才提到的具体技巧，即准备、启示和验证的概念而言，艾米的故事是如何体现这些阶段的呢，肯？在她开始问自己“问题是什么？我真正想要什么？”之前，什么都没有发生。在那之后很长一段时间里也没有发生什么，因为这是一个大问题。她的潜意识花了一段时间来处理它。但后来那个大脑找到了方法，将她过去的相关形象带入她的注意中。
But she still needed to recognize the aha moment. And then she still needed to elaborate it and follow it through and contact her friend and so forth. But the whole sequence fits this model that we've discussed quite well. You know, it's so interesting when you think about it, so few of us actually ask ourselves those big questions, and those of us who do often don't listen to the voice of illumination that might pop up, and then those of us who do that might not actually stop to verify or elaborate it and it really is several different steps and each of them is actually quite
但她仍然需要识别出那个顿悟时刻。然后她仍然需要阐述它并付诸行动，联系她的朋友等等。但整个序列非常符合我们讨论的这个模型。你知道，当你想到这一点时，这非常有趣，我们中很少有人真正问自己那些大问题，而我们中那些问了的人往往不听可能浮现出来的启示之声，然后我们中那些做了的人可能实际上并没有停下来去验证或阐述它，这确实是几个不同的步骤，每一个实际上都相当
important. Yes it is true they're all important and the process can be stalled anywhere along the way. One of the biggest problems Amy had was when she had this invitation to join her friend's company was making the cut from her old job because she knew that her old colleagues would see it as a step down, you know, working for so much less, so much less status. And so she needed to muster the courage to go ahead and take stuff anyway. One of the subtle traps that you have studied is the idea that once we make choices, our minds are very good at coming up with reasons
重要。是的，确实如此，它们都很重要，而且这个过程在任何阶段都可能停滞。艾米遇到的最大问题之一是，当她收到加入朋友公司的邀请时，要从旧工作中辞职，因为她知道她的旧同事会认为这是一种倒退，你知道，为了少得多的钱，少得多的地位而工作。所以她需要鼓起勇气继续前进。你研究过的微妙陷阱之一是，一旦我们做出选择，我们的大脑非常擅长想出理由
why those choices are, in fact, the correct choices. It becomes very difficult to actually evaluate the choice really on its own merits. Can you talk about that idea that there is a commitment that happens inside our minds once we've decided to go down path A rather than path B? Yes, Peter Goldwoods there in his great research has shown that at some point we cross a Rubicon of decision. And what that means is we make up our minds.
为什么这些选择实际上是正确的选择。要真正根据其自身的优点来评估选择变得非常困难。你能谈谈那个观点吗，即一旦我们决定走A路径而不是B路径，我们的内心就会产生一种承诺？是的，彼得·戈尔德伍兹在他的伟大研究中表明，在某个时刻，我们跨越了决策的卢比孔河。这意味着我们下定了决心。
We're no longer thinking about what we might want. We've now made a choice and we're going to go ahead with it. And what his research shows is that once we cross that Rubicon from deliberation to implementation, our minds operate very differently. We're no longer questioning what we're thinking. Instead we're trying to make plans. We're trying to preserve the goal. We don't want to wimp out on it. We want to take the next step. We don't want to have to go back to that uncomfortable position of wondering what we want.
我们不再考虑我们可能想要什么。我们现在已经做出了选择，我们将继续执行它。他的研究表明，一旦我们跨越了从审议到实施的卢比孔河，我们的大脑运作方式就会大不相同。我们不再质疑我们在想什么。相反，我们正在尝试制定计划。我们正在尝试维护目标。我们不想在它面前退缩。我们想采取下一步。我们不想回到那种想知道我们想要什么的令人不舒服的位置。
In some ways, we become almost prosecutors. We're basically a massing evidence for a conclusion that we've already reached instead of having an open mind. That's exactly right. We don't want to think that I chose the wrong thing. That creates dissonance, it's uncomfortable, and so we protect ourselves from that thought. And many times, that's a good thing. We don't want to let ourselves worry too much. We want to get on with things.
在某些方面，我们几乎变成了检察官。我们基本上是在为我们已经得出的结论收集证据，而不是保持开放的心态。完全正确。我们不想认为我选择了错误的事情。这会产生认知失调，这很不舒服，所以我们保护自己免受那种想法的影响。很多时候，这是一件好事。我们不想让自己担心太多。我们想继续做事情。
But sometimes that dissonance can be a valuable signal, as we've been talking about with Amy, that can let us know that maybe it is time to go back to the deliberation phase. Once we take the time to really look inward and listen to the quiet voices within us, there is still an important hurdle to overcome. Just because Amy discovered what felt like her true calling doesn't mean that the rest of her life is going to be a bed of roses. Getting to self-concordance is a great way to harness the power of intrinsic motivation and to start to live your life in accordance with your deepest values.
但有时这种失调可能是一个有价值的信号，正如我们一直在谈论艾米时所说的那样，它可以让我们知道也许是时候回到审议阶段了。一旦我们花时间真正向内看并倾听我们内心安静的声音，仍然有一个重要的障碍需要克服。仅仅因为艾米发现了她认为的真正使命，并不意味着她的余生都会是一帆风顺的。达到自我一致性是利用内在动机的力量并开始按照你最深层的价值观生活的好方法。
But changing course and making plans for a new life isn't enough. As boxing heavyweight champion and part-time psychologist Mike Tyson once said, everyone has a plan until they get punched in the mouth. I played Kenneth Clip from the movie Wild. It's based on a memoir by Cheryl Strade recounting her experiences hiking the Pacific Crest Trail. In this clip, Cheryl played by Reese Witherspoon is hiking. She's carrying a very heavy backpack and starting to regret her choices. Do you know what you're making sure? I like to sit on a real toilet with blush, like to cook food, eat food with other people. People, that's the other thing I like.
但改变方向并为新生活制定计划是不够的。正如重量级拳击冠军兼业余心理学家迈克·泰森曾经说过的，每个人都有计划，直到他们被重重一击。我播放了电影《走出荒野》中的肯尼斯·克利普片段。它基于谢丽尔·斯特雷德的回忆录，讲述了她徒步太平洋屋脊步道的经历。在这个片段中，瑞茜·威瑟斯彭饰演的谢丽尔正在徒步旅行。她背着一个非常沉重的背包，开始后悔自己的选择。你知道你在做什么吗？我喜欢坐在真正的马桶上冲水，喜欢做饭，和别人一起吃饭。人，这是我喜欢的另一件事。
I like talking to people, listening to people, I guess it's probably one I to hide me when I had new rules I had Until I decided to walk on my own to the f***ing dirt So the Pacific Crest Trail that we hear about in the movie can run some 2,600 miles from Mexico to Canada You've studied the motivations of people who successfully complete the trail in a single spring, summer season. What do you find happens to their intrinsic motivation as the trail unfolds? Yeah, this was a really interesting data. The most dramatic thing that happened was that their intrinsic
我喜欢和人交谈，听人说话，我想这可能是我有新规则时隐藏我的原因，直到我决定独自走在那些该死的泥土上。所以我们在电影中听到的太平洋屋脊步道可以从墨西哥到加拿大延伸约2600英里。你研究过在春季、夏季的一个季节里成功完成步道的人的动机。你发现随着步道的展开，他们的内在动机发生了什么？是的，这是一个非常有趣的数据。发生的最戏剧性的事情是，他们进行徒步旅行的内在
motivation to do the hike plummeted over the course of the summer. It no longer seemed so interesting and challenging and fun at the end. Instead, it was much more of a slog for most people who were able to go that far. You found that when intrinsic motivation wins in this way, it can actually be replaced by something else, a different reason for pushing forward, but one that is still positive. It's called identified motivation. What is this can?
动机在整个夏天急剧下降。到最后，它看起来不再那么有趣、具有挑战性和令人愉快了。相反，对于大多数能够走那么远的人来说，这更像是一种苦差事。你发现当内在动机以这种方式获胜时，它实际上可以被其他东西所取代，一种推动前进的不同原因，但仍然是积极的。这被称为认同动机。这是什么，肯？
Yeah, identified motivation is the kind where it's not that you're doing it because it's fun and interesting. Instead, it's you're doing it because it's meaningful and expresses your values and it's important to you. And so even when intrinsic motivation fails, identified motivation can still keep going, because it believes in the journey, even if the journey is now becoming more and more painful. You know, it's so interesting. A lot of this research I think speaks to the importance of mindfulness, of being, you know, willing to listen and pay attention to where you are and how you might really feel.
是的，认同动机是那种你不是因为有趣和有意思才去做，而是因为你有意义，表达了你的价值观，并且这对你很重要。所以即使内在动机失败了，认同动机仍然可以继续前进，因为它相信这段旅程，即使这段旅程现在变得越来越痛苦。你知道，这太有趣了。我认为很多这项研究都说明了正念的重要性，即愿意倾听并关注你所处的位置以及你可能真正感受到的。
I'm not quite sure it goes all the way back to that S seminar that you did in your 20s, but to some extent some of it is about, you know, really paying attention to where you are. It's true, and that is something that we all need to know how to do better. It's something that our schools don't teach us, our parents don't teach us. We're self-programming organisms. We are creating our lives via our choices, but we are not taught how to do it well, not taught how to ask ourselves the questions that will get us the answers that we need. Psychologist Ken Sheldon works at the University of Missouri. He's the author of
我不确定它是否一直追溯到你在20多岁时参加的那个S研讨会，但在某种程度上，其中一些是关于，你知道，真正关注你所处的位置。这是真的，这是我们所有人都需要知道如何做得更好的事情。这是我们的学校不教我们的，我们的父母不教我们的。我们是自我编程的有机体。我们通过我们的选择创造我们的生活，但我们没有被教导如何做好它，没有被教导如何问自己那些能给我们所需答案的问题。心理学家肯·谢尔顿在密苏里大学工作。他是
Freely Determined, what the new psychology of the self teaches us about how to live. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Aaron. Thank you for inviting me.S. about how to live. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, and thank you for inviting me of how to great time. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
《自由决定：新自我心理学教我们如何生活》的作者。非常感谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，亚伦。谢谢你邀请我。关于如何生活。非常感谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，也谢谢你邀请我，度过了愉快的时光。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·黄、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。
A run-song hero this week comes from our sister podcast, Mayan Sunghero. In 1997, Azim Sharif was a 10th grader at a high school in Vancouver. He had an English teacher named Darrell Wakeham. He took on this kind of father role for a lot of kids who were at the time in sort of bad straits. Me included, it was a tough time for me. Personally, I had some family stuff going on was in a bad mental health position. He noticed that and kind of swooped in at a time when I really needed somebody to do so,
本周的无名英雄来自我们的姐妹播客“无名英雄”。1997年，阿齐姆·谢里夫是温哥华一所高中的十年级学生。他有一位英语老师叫达雷尔·韦克汉姆。他为当时处于困境中的许多孩子扮演了这种父亲的角色。包括我在内，那对我来说是一段艰难的时期。就个人而言，我家里发生了一些事情，心理健康状况很糟糕。他注意到了这一点，并在我真正需要有人这样做的时候伸出了援手，
and I remember him saying, I know you don't think you're important enough for somebody to care about this, but you are. You are important enough. And it was just such a reassuring thing for somebody who's, you know, reeling at the age of 15. Darrell introduced Azeem to psychology and sparked an intellectual curiosity in him. Eventually, Azeem became a teacher himself, a psychology professor. In my intro-psych class, the last class is always a class on positive psychology. I always leave the students with these three tasks which have been empirically demonstrated to actually improve people's happiness for several months. One of them is this thing called the gratitude
我记得他说过，我知道你不认为自己重要到有人会关心这一点，但你是。你足够重要。对于一个15岁时感到不知所措的人来说，这真是一件令人安心的事情。达雷尔向阿齐姆介绍了心理学，并激发了他的求知欲。最终，阿齐姆自己也成为了一名教师，一名心理学教授。在我的心理学入门课上，最后一节课总是关于积极心理学的。我总是给学生留下这三个任务，这些任务已被实证证明确实可以在几个月内改善人们的幸福感。其中之一就是所谓的感恩
visit. Basically, what you do is you pick an unsung hero and you write 350 words, thanking them. If you can see them in person, you go up to them and you read this, and it turns out to be this extremely powerful visit, this extremely powerful moment for both people involved. And every year I would think of the same guy, this English teacher, from way back in the day. But every year, even though I was asking my students to do this, I was a big hypocrite, because I never did the gratitude visit for him. In 2018, Azim moved back to Vancouver and one day he decided to go to the beach.
拜访。基本上，你所做的是挑选一位无名英雄，写350个字感谢他们。如果你能亲自见到他们，你就走过去读给他们听，结果发现这对双方来说都是一次极其有力的拜访，一个极其有力的时刻。每年我都会想到同一个人，那位很久以前的英语老师。但每年，尽管我要求我的学生这样做，我却是一个大伪君子，因为我从未为他进行过感恩拜访。2018年，阿齐姆搬回了温哥华，有一天他决定去海滩。
And it is a clothing optional beach. It's a great beach. It's got such a lively culture there. I was down there, clothed. And so there he was, completely naked, throwing a frisbee, and I thought, now is my chance, and my chance is coming when he has no clothes on, and this is very awkward. Because usually you don't see your 10th grade English teacher completely naked, and when you do, it's awkward to approach him. And so then I kind of, I thought, should I go? Should I go talk to him now? And the awkwardness was too much.
那是一个服装可选的海滩。那是一个很棒的海滩。那里有非常活跃的文化。我在那里，穿着衣服。所以他就那样，完全赤裸，扔着飞盘，我想，现在是我的机会了，我的机会来了，当他没穿衣服的时候，这非常尴尬。因为通常你不会看到你的十年级英语老师完全赤裸，当你看到时，接近他会很尴尬。所以我当时想，我应该去吗？我现在应该去和他谈谈吗？那种尴尬太强烈了。
So I didn't talk to him. Until later, he put on a srong because that's what people seemed to wear on this beach and was walking by. And I said, hey, Darryl, and he recognized me, he remembered me. And I gave him what I'd been preparing in my head four years, which is this 350-word statement of gratitude,
所以我没和他说话。直到后来，他穿上了一条纱笼，因为那是人们在这个海滩上似乎穿的东西，正走过。我说，嘿，达雷尔，他认出了我，他记得我。我给了他我多年来在脑海中准备的东西，也就是这篇350字的感恩声明，
which was about the inspiration that teachers and students who eventually become teachers pass down to each other. to play a similar role for my students that he played for me, it gives some sort of meaning to the struggles that I had. I don't like to romanticize what I went through too much, but the ability to potentially help some people make all of that worth it. And I think it was the same thing for him. He was able to channel his own struggles into something which made it worth it by helping other people.
这是关于教师和最终成为教师的学生之间传递的灵感。为我的学生扮演与他为我扮演的类似的角色，这让我所经历的挣扎有了某种意义。我不喜欢过度浪漫化我的经历，但能够潜在地帮助一些人让这一切变得值得。我想对他来说也是一样。他能够将自己的挣扎转化为某种让他觉得值得的事情，通过帮助其他人。
It's a paying-it-back thing, right? Azim Sharif, he's a psychology professor at the University of British Columbia and a former guest on Hidden Brain. You can hear him in our episode titled Creating God. We reached out to Darrell to ask for his thoughts on a Zeme. He tells us that a Zeme was one of the brightest minds he ever worked with in nearly 40 years of teaching.
这是一种回报，对吧？阿齐姆·谢里夫，他是不列颠哥伦比亚大学的心理学教授，也是“隐藏的大脑”的前嘉宾。你可以在我们题为“创造上帝”的剧集中听到他的声音。我们联系了达雷尔，询问他对阿齐姆的看法。他告诉我们，阿齐姆是他近40年教学生涯中合作过的最聪明的头脑之一。
And he says, A Zeme's thank you at the beach that day made him remember why he became a teacher in the first place. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
他说，那天在海滩上阿齐姆的感谢让他记起了他当初为什么成为一名教师。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次重申，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有用，请尽你的一份力量帮助我们茁壮成长。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。